we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a great little
voicemail caller's mom watches the show
on Tick Tock listen to this
hi David Ryan here from Iowa I uh
I just went home to visit my
uh quite elderly mother and
I noticed
she was watching you on Tick Tock when I
came in and I thought I recognized your
voice
faster if
that was David pagman she said she had
to go back and she said yeah
I told her I subscribe to you and I paid
for the bonus show and
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money yeah everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves as bad right
you're great
oh thank you you know super interesting
we're all aware of all of the problems
with Tick Tock as a platform this has
nothing to do with that in terms of tick
tock as a place to get our message out
because we're using the tools where
there is an audience the growth we have
seen on Tick Tock is wild and even
though Tick-Tock audiences skew younger
overall we have not only a young
audience on Tick Tock like in the 13 to
13 to 24.
which is a little younger than like our
core audience which is like 24 to 54. we
also have a sizable 65 plus audience on
Tick Tock just the other day at a
pharmacy
um an older woman came up to me and said
I watched you're the guy from Tick Tock
so
Pleasant The Tick Tock regulation stuff
is going to get sorted out
as a platform it has been a huge place
to get our message out at this point I
think I'm getting recognized as much for
being on Tick Tock as being on YouTube
and it's beautiful to hear this
heartwarming message from the caller
okay great bonus show for you today
the military coveted vaccine mandate may
be ending
and it might be Biden doing it I thought
he was just gonna do all mandates well
apparently not we will talk about the EU
allowing phone calls on flights why
aren't phone calls allowed on flight
well uh why aren't phone calls allowed
on flights we will talk about it and
also New Zealand plans a lot to require
Facebook and Google to pay for news to
pay who what does that mean we will talk
about all of it on today's bonus show
you can sign up at joinpakman.com